Hey Crazies.
Once or twice, you might have heard someone say something like:
The fabric of the universe!
There’s not really a fabric though.
It’s just an analogy.
It’s meant to make space and time sound more tangible, like something that can be changed.
But what if there was a fabric?
How elastic would it be?
This episode was made possible by generous supporters on Patreon.
The interaction between spacetime and matter is governed by Einstein’s equation.
It looks something like this, which can be a bit intimidating.
Ok, it’s a lot intimidating.
But all this stuff is really just one thing:
spacetime curvature.
This other thing is the energy in that spacetime.
More energy means more curvature.
Less energy means less curvature.
As John Wheeler once said:
“Spacetime tells matter how to move and matter tells spacetime how to curve.”
What’s that have to do with elasticity though?
More than you might think.
We’ll set this thing aside and come back to it later.
Milton has been bugging me for a lately job anyway.
He can hold onto it for us.
[Alien Noises]
Space Aliens. Can’t take them anywhere.
Anyway, let’s talk about elasticity for a minute.
We’ll start with the easiest example: a spring.
The tension in a spring is just a constant times how much it stretched.
We call that constant the “spring stiffness”
because the bigger it is, the more force it takes to stretch the spring.
The stiffer the spring, the less elastic it is, so that constant tells us about its elasticity,
which is exactly what we’re interested in.
This relationship is Hooke’s law.
The force is what we’d call an external cause.
For example, our spring has a weight hanging on it that causes it to stretch.
The stretch itself is what we’d call an internal response.
We’re all familiar with how things respond externally.
Newton’s second law says they accelerate,
but things also respond internally.
The ball compresses because the back of it accelerates before the front does.
Other causes can even make objects change shape.
An external cause will always result in some kind of internal response.
Generally, we’d write that like this, which is still called Hooke’s law
because that’s not confusing.
The response is proportional to cause.
The point is we have a general rule for elasticity, one that applies to more than just springs.
The formal names for these two measurements are stress and strain.
But I like cause and response better.
They’re less jargon.
Just like with springs, this constant measures how rigid the material is.
It’s the rigidity.
Isn’t that the opposite of what we want?
Hmm, I suppose you’re right.
Let’s take that constant and put it on the other side.
That way, the equation takes us from the cause to the response,
as it should be.
We’ll call one-over-rigidity “the elasticity” to make our lives easier.
I feel like I’ve seen a relationship like this before.
[Alien Noises]
Right! Right! Einstein’s equation!
Earlier, we saw that spacetime curvature is proportional to energy.
In fact, that energy is the reason spacetime curves,
which makes it the cause.
And the curvature is the response.
It’s the same [BEEP] equation!
That means, if spacetime were some kind of material, this constant would be its elasticity
and we happen to know what that constant is.
It’s on the order of 10-to-the-minus-43.
That’s 43 places after the decimal point,
which is very little elasticity.
Spacetime is super rigid.
And that definitely makes sense.
It takes the mass of something like a planet or moon to even notice gravity.
It’s the weakest of the fundamental forces because spacetime is so rigid.
Where did that constant come from though?
What do you mean? I just plugged stuff in and...
No no, I mean, why is it that number?
Oh! Because it has to be consistent with Newtonian gravity.
Every new model we come up with has to be consistent with older time-tested models.
Say we’ve got two rocks floating in space.
Each one of them has a mass.
Maybe one them is bigger than the other, it doesn’t matter.
Newton says they each experience a force
related to both of their masses and the distance between them.
Which is great and all, but forces aren’t actually that useful for deeper understanding.
I mean, they make intuitive sense to us.
It’s just we’ve found that writing laws in terms of energy instead makes them look less ugly.
To the timeline!
Newton’s law of gravity was developed in the 1660s.
But in 1813, Siméon Poisson
Siméon P. Siméon. Siméon.
Siméon Poisson.
Poisson.
[Laughing] [BEEP]
Siméon Poisson came up with an equation we now call Poisson’s equation,
which transforms Newton’s force law into an energy law.
Granted, it wasn’t called energy back then, but that’s what it was,
whether it was called that or not.
Basically, this says a change in energy across space is caused by a mass.
Actually, that’s not energy. That’s energy per unit mass or potential.
Also, that’s not mass. It’s mass density.
It doesn’t matter if we’re only looking at this conceptually.
This is energy adjacent and this is mass adjacent.
It’s close enough!
Ay Yi Yi.
If we map out those energy values across space near something like the Earth,
it looks like this.
It’s a bunch of negative numbers.
The Earth is creating something we call a “gravitational well.”
But, if we’re going to call it a well, we might as well imagine it as one.
Did you catch that? We might as well.
Because it’s a gravitational well.
I’m such a dork.
Let’s imagine that each of these numbers represents the depth of the well at that location.
In that case, we’d have something that looks like this, which should look familiar.
It’s the one graphic you usually see when someone is talking about curved spacetime.
Except, I just made it without using Einstein’s equation.
It’s made using Poisson’s equation, an equation based on Newtonian gravity.
Bubbles burst!
To be fair though, that gravitational well does look kind of like a fabric.
Almost like Poisson’s equation is just one step away from Einstein’s.
In fact, Einstein’s equation is also an energy equation.
Every term in here is also energy adjacent.
So, under the right conditions, it should simplify to Poisson’s equation.
And that’s exactly what happens.
We call it the Weak-Field Limit, in which we make two assumptions:
One!
The cause of the curvature is an object made of matter
and the particles in that object are moving slow compared to light.
Two!
The curvature is very close to zero.
It’s pretty much just the spacetime from special relativity
plus a smidge of curvature, just a smidge though.
Both of these assumptions are perfectly reasonable around something like the Earth,
where we’d expect Newton’s law of gravity to apply.
In the weak-field limit, Einstein’s equation looks like this,
which is only a constant factor away from Poisson’s equation.
It’s the same [BEEP] equation,
at least in the weak-field limit.
Of course, the fabric analogy is just that, an analogy, and all analogies have problems.
For one, real-life materials don’t always have a proportional response.
If you stretch them too much, they can permanently deform or even break.
Spacetime’s response is always proportional.
That might make you think spacetime is simpler, but it’s just complicated in other ways.
For example, I’ve been displaying it as a two-dimensional surface because that’s easy,
but that’s a terribly inaccurate visual.
Spacetime isn’t two-dimensional. It’s four-dimensional.
Both the cause and the response are represented by four-dimensional tensors,
each with 10 unique components.
The weak-field limit only uses one of them.
Most of the gravity humans experience on Earth isn’t even space curvature.
It’s time curvature.
So how elastic is the fabric of the universe?
Not very elastic at all actually.
It’s on the order of 10-to-the-minus-43.
It takes a ridiculous amount of matter or light in one place to even notice gravity.
Spacetime might not actually be a fabric, but, whatever it is, it’s pretty rigid stuff.
So, how many of your bubbles did I burst today?
Please share in the comments.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
A special thanks goes out Nikolaos Vasiloglou...
Vasiloglou? Vasiloglou?
...for being one of our new orderlies on Patreon.
If you can help out, even $1 per month on Patreon gets you access to our monthly live Q&A.
YouTube Channel members have access too!
Don’t forget to subscribe if you’d like to keep up with us.
And until next time, remember, it’s ok to be a little crazy.
To everyone complaining about how I ignored air resistance in my Earth-tunnel.
Of course I did!
Do you think I’d go through the trouble of drilling a hole all the way through the Earth
and then not evacuate the air?
Pfffft! Come on crazies.
Anyway, thanks for watching!